we are peaceful people we are loving
people we love everybody who loves us
but we don't love anybody who doesn't
love us
this week marks 56 years since civil
rights activist malcolm x was
assassinated right here in new york city
for decades there have been many
questions around the circumstances of
his death
and whether the three men convicted of
his murder were actually the people
responsible
well at a news conference last saturday
malcolm x's daughter heard a letter for
the very first time
that they say is evidence that the nypd
and the fbi conspired to have their
father assassinated
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller explains
what this could mean for malcolm x's
legacy
white people don't realize how
frustrated negroes have become
malcolm x was a legendary orator
charismatic
controversial revolutionary to
lift the struggle for freedom of the
negro in this country
from the level of civil rights to the
level of human rights
on february 21st 1965 he was
assassinated while giving a speech at
the audubon ballroom in harlem
now 56 years later a letter given to
malcolm x's daughters
could hold proof the nypd and the fbi
conspired to have him killed i am
relieved that i am able to share this
truth
with the world today reginald wood reads
the words of his cousin
former undercover cop raymond wood who
died in november
he wrote that letter in 2011 to be
released upon his death
it was my assignment to draw the two men
into a felonious federal crime
so that they could be arrested by the
fbi
those men were members of malcolm x's
security detail
and were arrested days before his
assassination
there was no security to prevent the
gunman from coming into the building
three members of the nation of islam
were convicted
of the murder malcolm's death never sat
right with me
on the heels of the 2020 netflix
documentary
who killed malcolm x the manhattan
district attorney's office began a
preliminary review
last february after the letter's release
it says
their review remains active and ongoing
as for the nypd and the fbi they say
they have turned over
all their relevant records to the d.a
and will cooperate for cbs this morning
michelle miller new york first on cbs
this morning malcolm x's daughter that's
ilyasa shabazz and civil rights attorney
ben crump join us to discuss
good to see you both i want to start
with you ilyasa because i can't imagine
what it was like for you as his daughter
hearing those words for the first time
on saturday what were your thoughts as
you heard them
wow well um first good morning gail it's
a it's a pleasure to be here with you
um when we first heard that letter
it made us think of our father who was
just in his 20s
when he burst onto the scene of the
civil rights movement and 39
when he was gunned down when he was
assassinated in 1965.
he gave the biggest critique of america
and he wanted america to live up to her
promise
of liberty and justice for all and we
have seen historically the unjustice
against black americans primarily
and my father worked diligently
to ensure the end of this
senseless brutality were you surprised
by the words
were you surprised to hear what the
officer said
i can say i was surprised because i was
caught off guard
but it's something that my family and
many
always wondered um but most importantly
we wanted
to ensure that the truth
is uncovered ben crump i know that they
uh
good to see you ben and we should say
you're not representing the family
at this time but i know the wood family
brought the letter to you
in november why was it not revealed
until last weekend
well one of the things reggie wood
wanted to know
gail when he came to me what do i do
with this do i
turn it to the federal government to the
fbi
and the question was would they simply
just
suppress it as uh this had been a secret
for 56 years
that ray wood had carried under duress
he had been told that there would be
personal harm to him
and his family if he ever told people
about
the fbi and the nypd
conspiring to assassinate malcolm x
and so gail this is about restorative
justice
trying to vindicate those who have been
wrongfully convicted
by raywood nypd and the fbi people like
panther 21
including tupac shakur's mother a
faintish accord
those two men who spent almost three
decades in
prison to keep ray's secret
uh you know for trying to discredit
civil rights leaders in in
malcolm's case and many believe in fred
hampton and martin luther king's case
led to their deaths yeah yasa i'm
curious given what mr crump just said
about officer wood the late officer wood
i'm very curious what you think of him
today on the one hand he's written this
letter so the information is now
out there but on the other hand he was
part of it back then
and he was silent for so many years
well listen
my parents home was firebombed
on valentine's eve as they both lay in
bed asleep
a bomb was thrown in the nursery of
their
babies room where my sisters and i slept
one week later my mother witnessed
this horrific assassination of her
husband
she was a young woman with four babies
and pregnant with twins
and i know that she was excited to walk
into that
audubon ballroom that sunday afternoon
to see her husband and she walked out
shattered she tended to his knees
and opened his tie and
you know in spite of all of this trauma
that she endured
she raised her six daughters daughters
with
love kindness joy um
you know i just take my hat off to her
mother yes and
we can find out the truth
we could find out the truth we also we
don't have much time left i know ben
you've called for
a commission on this but i'm curious
elias about
what do you think is the biggest
misperception about your dad and do you
think his message is being perceived
differently these days
can you say it in a couple of weeks now
that yes i can
young people were politicized this
summer when they witnessed the death
of george floyd i think that many people
are now turning to malcolm
because they realize that malcolm had a
profound reaction to
these horrific injustices that continue
to occur
uh even today all right it'll be also so
bad still there are so many questions
that need to be answered and i hope that
you get them ben crump
thank you thank you thank you for
bringing this letter to life